so jetzt haben wir eigentlich schlechte
nachricht das große elend in berlin geht
natürlich trotzdem weiter
dabei ist der allerletzte kit der union
und spd in diesen tagen noch zusammen
hält die angst vor neuwahlen japanischer
bammel wegen ihrer aktuellen umfragen
sonst nichts
nur noch traurig beide ex volksparteien
haben in hessen überlegen sie es mal
letzten sonntag zweistellig verloren
katastrophe angela merkel hat völlig
recht wenn sie sagt und da hilft es auch
nichts dass auch diese landtagswahl wie
jede landtagswahl zunächst einmal nichts
anderes war als eine landtagswahl
ja das ist die große frage ob der
nächste vorsitzende auch so ein
brillanter redner wird wie sie leider
hat die groko gar nichts verstanden in
wirklichkeit von denen heißt jetzt immer
wir müssen unsere politik einfach besser
verkaufen ja genau
oder mal quer gedacht er versuchte es
doch mal mit einer anderen politik echte
maßnahmen gegen diese verarsche oder
explodierende mieten als vorschlag aber
klar am ende kannst du dir alles
schönreden
unser einsatz hat sich gelohnt vor einer
woche hat man uns maximal 26 25 prozent
zugenommen
und jetzt sind es 27
simon says
1,3 prozent verloren mein gott das
feiern die wirklich noch deprimierender
ist nur die situation bei den
sozialdemokraten oder das sieht mich so
runter wahnsinn die cdu hat jetzt nach
der merkel sensation wenigstens neue
hoffnungsträger das hat die union bei
denen belebt ein offener richtungsstreit
die partei und was machen die armen
setzen
sie waren gedemütigt
[Musik]
schon wieder vom himmel geschickt spd 20
und hatte eine frau die rettende idee
deshalb bestehen wir darauf dass sich
diese koalition einen klaren
verbindlichen fahrplan gibt gott
die spd hat ab sofort einen fahrplan
laden nach super was ist das ganz
einfach beschreiben die sitzen jetzt
noch mal alles rein was sowieso schon im
koalitionsvertrag steht
geil frau nahles kündigt jetzt einen
fahrplan für die weitere arbeit der
großen koalition was soll das denn sein
mann lindner
fragt doch nicht so blöd es ist ein
fahrplan
du bist doch nur neidisch weil du keine
nass spd ab sofort mit fahrplan
glücklich in den unternehmen
die genossen sind gerettet
sie haben einen fahrplan in hessen
wussten 64 prozent der wähler nicht mehr
wofür die spd steht das zu klären wäre
eventuell fast wichtiger als ein
fahrplan aber nur meine meinung
jetzt aber sie haben sicher darauf
gewartet zum eigentlichen skandal der
hessen wahl vom letzten wochenende die
afd wurde von den verdammten
staatsmedien schon wieder totgeschwiegen
nach 40 minuten ist york wollten
der in wiesbaden war das erste mal
sozusagen im bild mit einem statement
gewesen 40 minuten kamen wir als afd der
eigentliche wahlsieger gar nicht vor
bekam überhaupt nicht vor
über 40 minuten ich meine klar
in herrn baulands alter sind auch 40
minuten kostbare keine frage
kleiner haken opa hat gelogen um 18 23
also 23 minuten nach der ersten prognose
war am morgen in der ard und elf minuten
vorher war der hessische fdp-vorsitzende
beim hr live auf sendung
bauland ist trotzdem stinksauer dazu kam
dass ich extra nach berlin gefahren bin
mir wurde schon auf der fahrt gesagt
dann das sei nicht nötig man brauche
keine stellungnahme er ist extra nach
berlin gefahren mit der reichsbahn
und dann wollte man die nicht ganz
ehrlich da schäme ich mich wirklich für
meinen eigenen sender zur
wiedergutmachung haben wir zum glück
jetzt live zugeschaltet ich bin sehr
froh darüber alexander gauland helgoland
erstmal wirklich sorry für sonntag und
meine frage jetzt wo die fdp endlich in
allen landtagen sitzt können sie da auf
helgoland sorry wir müssen leider
schluss machen ich höre gerade im
wuppertaler zoo hat nach sein wie diesen
ein stofftier bekommen ist das eine
mesic
so süß
ja
eine entschuldigung fand ich halt
spannender die afg ist nun wirklich oft
genug im fernsehen und wenn man sie live
schaltet dann passiert sowas hier wie
letzten sonntag in hessen
und ich glaube das ist eine
nationalhymne als dank an die wähler an
unser land wert
streit und recht und freiheit
das deutsche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie lachen meine damen und herren aber
wir mussten die hunde aller einschläft
[Musik]